ever since the night his window was
shattered when someone threw a rock
through it Alexander boob ship has had
trouble sleeping look Christine yes that
was a warning shot supposedly then I got
a threatening message online it said be
glad it was only a rock this time
Alexander viv chev lives with his mother
in this one-room flat he's lost track of
the number of times police have come
here and Rance acted that's because the
authorities consider him an extremist
they even blocked his bank account his
colleagues and former friends along with
the rest of the community view him as a
traitor who deserves to be put on trial
this was to necto cucina the court has
called in students as witnesses I was
called a pervert in their presence as an
enemy of Russia I was deemed unfit to
have any contact with children yet skill
douche and it's all because of a poem
bitshare published in the ukrainian
language a year ago its title to the
Ukrainian insurgents is an ode to the
people of Ukraine and their stand off
against what some translate as the
Moscow gangsters those supporting
Ukrainian separatists citing hate speech
and extremism Russian authorities
carried out a year-long investigation of
Bibb chef this week he was sentenced to
a year of community service with an
additional punishment but switching
leave late because the accused poses a
potential danger to the young generation
he is hereby forbidden from practicing
his profession as a teacher the luggage
confused Alexander boob chef taught at
his school for 20 years now he's not
allowed to enter the premises ever again
I've been accosted what this really
hurts 20 years is half my life now it
seems I spent them all in vain Pushpa
Leo as we approach the school without
camera rolling the entrance to the
building is blocked on the streets of
this small community 400 kilometers
south of moscow no one will speak to us
the court has turned Alexander Biff ship
into an outcast in his own village
as the fate of the school teacher was
decided in this courthouse the fate of a
Russian men who just wanted to publicly
express his sympathy towards Ukraine the
fact that this man was condemned shows
that the atmosphere of fear and
intimidation reaches far into the
Russian provinces